如果大家想在这个VR slave里面找到我的话
可以找那个HELENZO这个名字
然后呃我是red hat啊
Machine learning engineer
然后是我们这个VRMM呃
生态系统里面speculators这个库的呃
Maintainer
然后今天主要想给大家呃分享一些呃
投机推理的原理
然后我们speculators这个库
然后再到DSC嗯
最近嗯新推出的这个算法
DISPARK还有如何利用啊
我们是如何利用e r arm monkey connector
还有speculators来训练一些投机解码的drafter的
嗯那么本次分享我们由浅到深
先先来呃介绍一下这个投机解码的原理
然后对这个训练框架做一个简单的梳理
之后介绍d spark究竟是怎么工作的
然后到这个会稍微浅显地讲一些
这个集群规模训练
怎么样提取这个隐藏状态
Hidden states
呃
以及怎么使用这个为什么要使用这个wink connector
首先投机解码到底是什么啊
对于不太了解的同学嗯
我觉得有一个呃比较好理解的例子
比如说我们使用这个ANTHROPIC的coding agent
这样的服务嗯
有些简单的场景呢
它就会呃调用这个呃简单一点的模型
比如sonnet这个模型要复杂一点的问题
才会调用到更强大的模型
Fable
这个投机解码就是把这个想法运用到比较极致
因为现在的大模型可以说是越做越大了啊
从几个嗯billion parameter到现在呃
这个terabytes的model呃的模型
那么对于一个非常大的模型
我们给他训练一个特别特别小的模型
大部分时候呢我就用这个小的模型来啊进行呃
大部分的呃计算
然后呃提出一些token
然后只有在特别特别困难的情况下啊
我们去跑这个大模型
然后用这个大的模型来验证我们小模型的呃
一些草稿
那么这样我们就可以省掉一些嗯呃时间
让这个部署变得快起来
那么它具体是怎么工作的呢
比如说像我们经典的一个ego three
这样一个小的模型
它就是一个一般来说就是一个非常小的
transformer的一层
那这个小模型它能够提议嗯
他能够提议token
他可以打一些草稿
像ego three
我们一般就是提议三个或者5~5个
那新一点的模型
像DEFLASHDESPARK嗯
我们一般可以提18~16个呃
那么提议的方式有不不一样
一种是这个小模型
它也是自回归的题
就是小模型他自己跑三次前项
然后生成三个token
另外像d flash或者d spark或者P1狗
它就是一次生成8~16个token
他就只跑一次前项
他也不做自回归
连小模型的多次前项都省略掉
那么跟这个呃自回归的小模型相比
它就更快嗯
然后一并把这些这8~16个token交给大模型
由大模型来啊验收
那么我们这里的例子就是小模型
他嗯提到了提了四个token
Jumps the lazy
那么target模型就一次收到
同时收到这四个token
那么他只需要跑一次前项嗯
就可以把呃在这一次里面把他们全部验证掉
嗯在验证的时候呢
因为他给自己也跑了一次前项
所以他它能够呃产生一个呃免费的token
这个dog是免费的
那么他什么时候决定接受
什么时候决定不接受啊
一个比较好理解
就是他呃这个target的模型
它这个大模型它觉得哦呃我对这个偷你
你提交的这个token还是比较自信的
甚至比比你这个模型更自信
那么我就会把它接收
像这个lazy就是就是你你这个token嗯
嗯你你虽然提出了
但是我不对这个token并不是很满意
我这个我这个算啊
算出来log probability
就是并没有你的log poly probability这么自信
当然实际上的采用没有这么简单呃
但是可以这样浅显地理解一下嗯
这个投机解码为什么
为什么我们在意这个投机解码为什么它好
就是因为它完全是无损的
那么我们这个大模型拒绝的过程当中呢
它能够呃保持这个target他的输出和你单独来呃
serve这样一个呃target的大模型是完全一样的
可是完全没有任何损失
和其他这些模型优化
传统的方式
像这个啊quantization量化或者specification相比
就是他没有任何的损失
只是做到一个单纯的加速
呃有什么问题吗
嗯呃直播间都是问PPT会跟回放一起对
呃没有什么问题
我们继续哦
哦哦可以可以
不过我有一个小问题
就是这个P1个话
我听这么说话
他也是这种呃DMM形式进行推理对吧
呃
DL就是呃
就是这个就就是我是善于是做这种双向注意力
然后一次推理很多个脱口对
他不是做自回归
他倒他倒不是这个注意力的远
他倒不是这个注
他这个注意力还是castle的
他就是使用一个就是这cod sampling
就是因为他要不然的话
他那个就是blow up
很快嘛
嗯我嗯我们可以之后单独单独解释
因为我知道ego我不太
我不是很清楚我批一狗是长什么样子的
嗯嗯他他和他和ego就是长一上涨差不多
主要就是一个嗯
就是训练的过程当中有一个memory saving这个technique
然后他又一个mask token也是嗯
就是来代替他那个呃
因为他现在是并行的预测了它
它就是没有这个前面一个token的信息
他就用一个mask token来代替
然后他另外有有一个呃嗯叫mask hn states
就是他来训练这个mask hen states
然后让他来代替那个那个
之前我们本来可以得到的那个自回归的那个
hans st的信息哦
然后直播间哦
直播间有同学开始问问题了
就是呃drifter给到target的那个logo pros
他的shape是什么样子的
它呃要根据不一样的模型
它shape就是不太一样嗯
嗯但是你看看你看你训练和influence的时候
一般就是我们有的时候会就是截取一些
就是前面就是比较比较比较自信的
因为他这也不大
他就是就是我们有的时候还会呃
还会就是做这个token这个embedding的
把它就是把reduce一下
因为实际上我们这个draft after
它不需要掌握这么多呃艰深的词汇
就是就是他可以用那个嗯
呃他的词汇量不需要那么大
它只需要把最常用的词汇量都掌握就可以了
嗯那么那我继续我继续嗯
我继续讲吧
那么呃我们我们这里就是可以看到嗯
有几个专有名词
我们之后可能会用到
在这里介绍一下
就是我们现在接受的这个呃jumps over the dog
这四个token
就是我们的平均就是我们的接受长度
然后这个接受长度越长呢
呃嗯就代表比如说四个token
我们本来是这个大的模型
他需要他需要跑呃
四次前项才能够产生四个token
那么现在我们只跑了一次前项
就产生了四个token
等于说我们省掉了三次
前项的这个计算和这个时间
还有这个unloading
offloading的这个这个这个这个work
那么那么我们这个嗯
我们这个观测到的加速就是非常可观的
那么加受接受程度越快
我们观测到的加速呢就越明显
那每一个位置它被接受的这个概率
我们就要接受率acceptance rates
那么每一个每一个位置他接受的呃
这个接受率越高
接受长度就越长
接受长度越长啊
那么我们要观测到的加速就越明显啊
所以我们就希望这个啊草稿模型
它的接受长度呃越长是越好
然后接受率越高是越好
就说明你这个小模型开始学会
像你这个大模型一样思考了
然后他说出来的话
也和这个大模型就是说的差不多
那么这样子的话
我们就能够起到一个加速的作用
嗯这里我想强调的有一点就是嗯
最开始投机推理
我们的想法是哎
我们可不可以用一个呃天问的小模型
给一个千万的大模型来进行加速
那么这两个模型它的输入
都是这个自然语言的输入啊
比如说比如说嗯用户说呃hello
How are you
那么小模型或输出
I'm fine
Thank you
然后这些token再拿到这个大模型里面去验证
然后但是从一的我们发现就是这样的加速
就是不太明显
嗯但是但是我们从呃ego three这个算法开始
他不再把这些自然语言的token作呃
作为我们这个draft小模型的输入了
他发现我们把这个大模型它PFL的时候
这个隐藏状态作为输入输入进去
那么大模型看到呃
Hello
How
Are you
让他跑一次前项做一些PFL产生啊
这么多就是这里看到的hen states
那我们从这个前中后啊
各取几层作为这个draft模型的这个输入
然后然后然后我们发现这样的话
draft模型等于就是它可以啊窥探到这个target
大模型就是一些呃思考的过程
那么它它生成的token质量就会比较高
那我们发现它的输出和大模型比较的时候
就比较相似嗯
那那那这样我们的接受率就比较高
然后接受长度就比较长
那么加速就比较明显
所以训练的时候
我们需要大量的这样的hen states
隐藏状态来作为训练的数据
然后帮助这个小的draft模型
学到这个大模型的思考过程
那么像ego three呃
是单层的
然后新的DEFLASHDESPARK
它是嗯他的structure
这个architecture是3~5层的
但是呃就是这个小模型虽然他有可能有几层
但是仍然和这个大模型相比嗯是要小很多的
所以这样我们就是这两个模型的体型
跟它相差越大
我们看到这个加速就很明显
那么speculators是什么
就是我们speculators这个库
它是一个从训练啊
我们这个嗯嗯训练我们这个draft呃模型
到比如说嗯我想用一个z lab
他们他们他们呃训练的这个嗯d flash的模型
我想把它转换一下
然后用我自己的嗯production
用我自己呃不呃
就这服务部署环境的这些数据
来给他做一个微调
Fine to
那么我们也支持我们也支持这项转换
然后微调这样的服务
然后再到这个部署上
我们保证就是所有啊我们这个呃speculators
他训练的这个模型可以直接在VM面部署
我们可以看它就是这个命令
它就只是一条
你就可以直接vm serve嗯
你训练好的模型
那么呃我们刚才讲这个训练的时候
需要额提取很多这个hen states
那么我们SPECULUM支持就是在线嗯
比如我们一边生成这些handsets隐藏状态
一边训练
然后或者是我们offline
我们离线
我们先生成呃
所有的我们需要的混合的这个hin state隐藏状态
然后然后再进行训练
或者是我生成一部分
然后一部分呢我一边训练
一边生成这个混合的状态
呃我们也是我们也是支持的
是非常灵活的一个呃
呃非常灵活的一个呃一个库
然后我们也支持这个呃MOE这个混合专家
然后或者vision language视觉视觉语言模型的训练
那么呃我们为了这个训练
也呃设计落地了很多工具
比如说我们支持用这个target模型啊
重新生成训练回复啊
为什么这一点很重要
因为如果你想给千问训练一个这个draft的模型
但是你你去用叉GBT的数据
或者用tm case three这样的数据去训练
那他就呃他就不不能学会
怎么样像千问一样说话啊
他这样的呃draft的模型
它也许能够产生有意义的token
但是它不能够特别好的给千万加速
因为它它跟千问说话的方式他不一样
他没有跟千问学
所以大部分我们的模型我们为它就是重新训练
这样draft的模型的时候
我们都需要用target这个模型去重新生成
它自己的特有的训练回复嗯
还有一点就是我们训练的时候
我们只想在训练大模型产生的这些token
然后像用户给的这个问题
这个prompt我们是不需要训练的
那么我们呃一般就是会给他呃计算一个这个呃
Lost mask
那么怎么样适配呃不一样的
这样chat chat template
我们也做了很多努力
现在在呃speculators里面
我们可以自动适配这些template
然后在训练的过程当中呢
我们也有TENSORBOARD
还有waiting bias这些嗯
工具能够让大家可以实时的看到你的训练曲线
如果你的模型训练到某个阶段已经在过拟合了
你可以很直观的看到
然后马上停下来
不用再继续浪费我们GPU的算力
还有部署
这里我们讲过所有啊
我们训练的模型是可以一键在这个VR2面
一个命令部署的
那么我接下来简单的介绍一下
我这个投机推理嗯
嗯speculation支持的算法啊
然后还有他们到底有什么不一样
嗯像我们刚刚讲过
刚才那页PPT
其实我有个小问题啊
就是我们这个speculators
他有和一些RL框架做一些集成的
嗯目前没有
但是我觉得未来可能会和这些2L
做一些继承对
因为我们现在RL的话
一般做rot都会默认会开一些投一解码的东西
然后我们如果开合解码的话
我们必然会在训练的时候
导致我们这个drift model会发生这个权重
跟训练权重发生偏移对吧
那么实际上我们必须得一起在训模型的时候
要训这个drift mode对
要两个一起训练
这样子的话呃效果也会比较好
接受率也会比较高
所以那些就是呃model provider
他们自己训练的这个啊draft模型
就是会比较有优势
因为它就是两个一起训练的
其实可以考虑跟我们VM生态里面的这个
RL框架VM进行一些合作
嗯是的是的是的
我觉得很有道理
我回去马上跟那个组里打报告
嗯那么我们讲过之前讲的这个传统的呃
这个就是用一个小模型
大模型加速
它就是我们比较过时了
然后效果也不是很好
而且他也不需要额外的训练
那我们是不支持啊
像ego three的话
就是我们最成熟呃
然后就是最经典的这个算法
那么就是我们前面讲的
我们把大模型的隐藏状态作为输入
然后我们一般是一个transformer的一个层
然后我们啊order aggressively
然后自回归的来给他打草稿
然后pee go
我们刚才简单的讲了一下
他就是他的啊
他的architecture和呃一个three是呃一样的
然后他就是在一个three的基础上
就是做啊多个token的预测
通过用一个mask kitten states
然后这个mask id
然后但它是并行的
然后还有这个cot sampling的这个啊
就是嗯嗯内存memory的saving technique
那它和ego three相比呢
它就是预测就会更快
嗯嗯在某些情况下
我们发现它的加速和低flash实际上差不多
然后DEFLASH呢它是不一样
像我们刚才讲到
他用一个像就是diffusion一样的呃
呃layer
然后在这个anchor position定一个就是锚点
然后做这个快的草稿预测
所以它也是并行的
和这个自回归的模型相比会快很多
那像MTP就是很多模型提供商
他们在发布模型的时候
他自己就会带一个MTP的头
那么很多模型
它本身已经具备了多token预测的能力
但是他仍然是自回归的
就是说这个draft打草稿的时候
是一个一个token来的
所以相比并行预测的话会慢一点
那么嗯DEBURG后面我们会着重介绍
他就是为什么特别好
因为为什么大家都在说这个
他就是他就是既有这个并行打草稿的速度
又有这个自回归的精确度
所以他是两全其美的
和我们这个模型带来的加速就非常可观
嗯接下来我还想提一下
就是我们red hat AI嗯
嗯我们自己也训练了28个不一样的draft model
你可以看到大部分是这个ego three
这是我们最成熟的算法
在VMM上的支持也是最稳定的
那我们还有七个不一样的d flash的模型
然后有一个d spark呃
因其实有很多DESPARK正在训练
我们会啊逐步的持续的发布他们
然后还有一个PEEGO的模型
然后我们会嗯持续不断的发布新的模型
然后也欢迎大家去试一试这些模型
让我们知道啊哪里可能有短板
哪里可能加速比较明显
那么在speculator上面
如何训练一个真正的drafter呢
那么我们只需要呃这个三条命令在SP嗯
我们有几个不同的脚本
首先是一个数据的脚本
我们啊我们通过这个就是prepare这个data
我们可以嗯呃计算我刚刚提到的这个loss mask
然后apply我们chat template
然后把把所有的这些呃自然语言的嗯
嗯训练的数据转化成这些token id
然后到我们这个training training这个训练可以啊
可以consume的这样一个状态
然后我们我们还有一个呃脚本
是我们启动这个VRMM的hen states
隐藏状态的提取服务器
然后因为这些都是呃v r arm它原生native的
所以呃我们能够得到这个VR arm啊
本身啊一些加速
就是相比用transformer训练的话会比较快
嗯最后就是呃我们train训练草稿模型
虽然这些这些命令可能看起来还是有点复杂
但是我们有很多呃tutorial
然后帮助大家理解
我们之后也会加一些cloud skill啊
嗯这样你呃你就是呃呃cloud
在阅读到这这个我们的库的时候
可以能够直接得到这些contact
就不用我们再去找
然后然后再然后再去再去呃
摸索那个每一个这个promise到底是什么意思
嗯直播间有同学问
像美杜莎头这种额头一解法
是不是现在已经用的不多了
对他就是相对来说算比较过时的一个呃
嗯算法了
然后他就是带来的加速
和哪怕和一个three相比来说都是比较有差距的
然后所以我们就是不去不选择支持他了嗯
因为这块他真的就是发展的很迅速
经常就是像之前domino也是刚出来
哎
他他他的想法和迪斯spark也差不多
但是我们最近做了一些实验
发现他就是不如迪斯spark
那那我们就选择就是不支持了
因为你现在在训练一个domino的话
就不如训练一个迪斯spark好
然后还有观众问
野生开发者想训练一个自己的这个drift model
那么数据从哪里找呢
嗯像我我我们呃训练的时候嗯
基本上是使用这个Mac pie和alter chat
这两个数据库
然后嗯deep sick的话
它的模型是用这个perfect bland
就是在哈利face it上面可以找到
然后我们也我们我们的那个刚才讲过那个
target图模型的呃
他这个response regeneration
我们我们就是这这两个这两个呃数据库
我们都是就是原生的支持的啊
如果你有就是自己就是特别就是呃
生态系统里面
你们在production有一些数据的话
也可以在一个模型的基础上面给它进行微调
进行翻to
那这样就不需要用到
特别特别特别多的这个数据啊
我们啊也有啊
我们也有和啊合作合作啊
和和和就是公司合作的时候
发现他能够得到比较好的效果
就是在某一个领域里面进行这个反清啊
这样好理解吧
嗯我也觉得就是因为毕竟这个drift model的话
相对于它权重占比都比较小对吧
那么他其实是可能你的模型
你希望他表现什么行为的话
那么你拿对应的那种数据来训练的话
可能会让他这个额接受率更高一些
对的是的
尤其是你这个嗯
你这个应用的场景比较单一的话
那么你你这个加速就是非常
就是你可以专门针对性的对它进行训练
你这个加速就是会非常可观啊
对然后其实我还有个问题啊
就是因为这个腿解码确实发展的非常的快
然后其实最开始的时候还有用什么
就是n gram这些东西来做推荐嘛
然后现在的话肯定基本上已经没有人会用了
那么你们有对于比如仓库里面这种很老的一些
推荐码的东西
就你们有把这代码直接删掉吗
嗯怎么说呢
就是我们发现新的这个投机解码算法出来之后
他会给这个旧的投机解码的这些算法呃
进行优化
像我们发现之前ego three
他是使用的就是呃lama的那个layers
他的他的draft模型
然后我们发现d flash出来的时候
AQUTHREE的那个layers比拉a layer效果就好
那么我们现在就支持啊
你可以训练一个宽three的ego
ego three的这个这样draft模型
那么第一次bug出来的时候
哎我们发现嗯他嗯他就是增加了一个Mark chain
一个confidence head
那那那就给这个d flash
进行了非常可观的这个优化
那么这些东西它它不仅仅是只适用于d flash
它也可以就是应用到呃
ego three甚至p go上面去啊
那这个库我们是不是一直在一直在做实验
一直在实践
然后我们就发现新的算法
给旧的算法也进行了优化
然后我们就是一直在就是比较
然后然后嗯然后做各种各样的oblations实验
然后看嗯哪种方法就是最成熟最好嗯
因为我问这个问题是
因为我记得在去年上半年的时候
当时其实万某他对于这个drive
就是整个头一解码支持都不是很好嗯
然后当时我记得
因为当时其实比较主流的
还是用一个大小模型去做的对吧
然后小模型的话
因为你的这个配置其实会跟大模型完全不同
就导致你的
而你的一般来讲
你会把它布在同样的一些设备上面
那么其实你会导致呃有的设备上
比如说你布置这个部署这个小模型
然后还有的设备上你就布不了小模型
你就会自然的造成很多这个GPUU
在ZATION的这些浪费
对吧
对对对对对
是这样对
然后因为我我现在不是没有怎么看这块代码的
所以我想知道因就像这种情况
我们是不是可以考虑
比如说把这种部署大小模型的这种投机解码
就直接把最后一部分代码就移除了
反正现在也没有人用了
是我不知道VR有没有完全把那块移除掉
但是我但是我们就是这些算法
在VM上面全部都是有支持的
然后然后我们也是会一直呃
我们每天都有在泡一些测试
确保他们这个环境是成熟稳定的
呃如果大家发现有什么问题的话
也欢迎你就是跟我们report
我们会马上在VR里面进行这个ah dum
那我们回到这个PPT
然后呃直播间还有同学问一个问题
我再回答一下
就是呃加速百分比多少算是训的比较好
或者加速的上限大概是多少倍
嗯嗯这是个好问题
嗯我们一般来说观测到
就是像3~5倍是比较正常的
那么有些他们可以说呃有些也可以呃
他们这个在论文里面或者啊怎么样也有
也有说是有6~86到八倍的
这个我是没有就是呃没有观测到这样的情况
但是我也没有说是就是假的
可能是他在本身就呃不太没有太优化过的
这个呃推理这个引擎上面可能会得到更更
就是就是dramatic这样的一个呃加速
但是像VR来说
我们一直都是用VR测试的话
我们发现这个3~5倍或者甚至六倍
是呃一个比较呃就是正常的区间
然后那在嗯投机推理它有一个这个限制
是
因为它本质是我用多一些的算力
去换取一个速度
那么在你本身就是这个引擎很繁忙
就是support这个computer band的时候
就是你很多很多request
你你这个算本身算力就不够了
你还要去用这个算力换
你就换不来速度
那么在这个场景下
我们就是不建议把这个投机推理
你就是大开
那么像VR现在也是支持
就是就是如果在呃request请求很多的时候
我们就直接把图形推理关掉呃
然后确保就是模型
它就是嗯不不花这些额外的就是计算compute嗯
而且我觉得这个3~5倍
应该也是跟你具体采用什么算法有关的
对的对的
以前跟算法也你说对
因为我觉得在1go和MTP时代的话
应该是很不很应该不可能做到3~5倍这么快
这么夸张的速度
没有没有没有一个对一个一个的话
他本身他每次一次也只是就是能够打
就是三个这样的这个
那么那么就是他一般acceptance l就是在嗯
二二点多三左右
那么那么就是额达不到三
这个有可能就是两倍
然后呃甚至有的时候两点几一点几倍都有啊
但现在d flash despark话就是越来越强大
他一个这个小模型也不是自回归了
然后他一个就是呃可以一次一次的啊
预测达到16的token
那么他这个acceptance
这个接受的长度可以做到很长
然后有人问
请问提升接受率有什么trick吗
嗯有一些我我知道的就是他呃训练的时候训练
比如说让这个模型来呃
呃打16个草稿
但实际上他啊在influence
在就是推理引擎上使用的时候
他只让他打到八个草稿
那么他这个exception states
就是呃我们观测到会比较高一点
嗯对就是你结你这个推测推测越傻话
那你自然这个接受率就会越高了
对对对对对
然后额头机解码哦
等一下我看一下呃
还有个问题
就是3~5倍是是在gm5.2上面测出来的吗
加加5.2呃
我我刚刚测了这个接受长度
然后然后他这个也是我们正在训练的一个模型
我我今天测的他这个接受长度
在不同的领域的这个额数据的表现上面啊
接受长度在3~5左右
但是我还没有就是测在具体的那个呃
然后如果感兴趣的话
你可以试一试这个模型
然后我们呃我们也是正在训练的这个过程当中
因为这个模型越大
他这个训练的时间就越长
然后我们在尝试使用那个perfect bland
那个那个呃100万的那个数据
比我们平时训练的那个数据要大很多
然后他就是比较慢一点嗯
然后还有同学问统一解码和LAURA是如何兼容的
啊这个是喵二这块
但这块不是我做的
我只知道他在喵二里面能做到兼容了
但是呃但是我不是特别清楚细节是怎么样的啊
呃就是同学如果感兴趣的话
下次可以我们请愿
让我们这边就是呃的呃同事来介绍一下啊
这是好问题
对这是个好问题回答哈哈哈
对这个他这其实更偏向一个工程上的问题了
对吧
对我也很好奇
嗯我们可以找下面后面找杰杰力
来这边介绍一下子
他们是怎么做的
嗯对的对的哦
因为我主要是做训练这边的
嗯嗯嗯但这个是好问题
那我们回到这个PPT吧
嗯就是我们每个模型它会自动就是呃
我们我们会say
我们会存一个CONFIG到JSON这个呃file
那么VR我们可以从这个CONFIG到JSON里面自动检测
我们用的是啊
比如说DISCORCH这个算法
然后呃我们这个hidden states的呃
隐藏状态到底要取哪几层
然后我们这个transformer layer到底是用的宽
three还是用的lama
然后然后你这个模型是三层的
一层的
五层的这些VR就是就是它自动的就能够检测到
所以你在呃部署的时候
只需要一条命令就可以直接部署呃
那么我们讲今天这个呃重要的diss spark
它的解码到底是怎么样啊怎么样啊
work的吧
就是为什么我们说迪斯SPA和其他算法比
比较强大
就是首先它和第一flash是同样的
就是用这样一个呃相当于diffusion的并行骨干
也就是一次前项它可以产出到8~16个token
然后这些token呢因为是
但是因为他们这些token是并行产出的
就是它是同时产出的
所以他没有前面这一个位置这个token的信息
那么这会产生什么情况
比如说呃你说thank you
那么我可以我既可以回复啊
No problem
我也可以回复
Of course
那如果是自回归的模型
第一个token我预测了of
第二个TOTOKEN我一定会预测course
因为我知道of course是一个相关的短语
但你在并行预测的时候呃
第一个token of course
NO problem都是有可能的
那我可能就预测了of
第二个token我我我也觉得既可能预测problem
那又可能预测course
那那如果我预测成了problem
这个短语就变成了of problem
那么输出就变成了胡言乱语了
他这个质质量就没有自回归的时候能够那么高
那么d spark的解法是
我在这个d flash已经输出这呃八个呃
到或者16个位置的这个log probability的时候
这个distribution的时候
那我给他加一个这个Mark of head
让模型能够学到这个token和token之间的关系
但又不要太笨重
那这个market hat
它就是一个轻量级的
这个这就是一个相当于是一个呃affinity matrix
就是他能够学习到就是呃一个token
他接下来会呃接哪一个token
如果额如果我第一个token是这个的话
那我下一个token是他
嗯呃韩红是你那边声音
呃能听到吗
哦可以听到可以听到哦
可以可以呃
那么他就是从左到右嗯
就是他他再给他嗯loop1遍
就是为呃
就是为下一个token的位置加一个比较low rank
低质的这样的一个bias
就是矫正一下我们并行时候产生的
可能互相没有关联的这个token
因为因为这个呃Mark pad它非常清亮
然后它既保留了这个并心骨干的速度
然后又修正了精确度
所以他就是又快
然后预测token又好
那么他不仅仅是做这些
他在这个基础上他还加了一个置信度头
就是confidence had
就是在我输出的时候
我不仅输出这些token
我还同时说出我对预测这个token到底有多自信
然后如果我对某些token本身就不是很自信
我索性不把它提交到这个targets模型里面去了
那么就进一步的为这个target模型减轻了工作量
那么减轻工作量也能够起到呃起到加速的作呃
作用呢还能省掉一些不必要的计算
那么这个论文里面deep seek他们发现嗯
对ego three相比
DESPARK可以达到30%的增长加速啊
对这个d flash有18%的增长
而增加这个啊
Mark of
这个这个这个头带来的延迟开销只有区区啊
0.22%到1.3
也就是说我们付出这个0.2到1.3
0%
0.2到1.3这样的代价
我们得到的加速度是18%
30%
这个优化是比较显著的
那么接下来我简单讲一下VR arm这个MODERRUNNER呃
Vr
他为了就是也不仅仅是为了部署这些
投那投机解码的模型
但是他这个优化在图机解码上就是可以观测到
就是它基本上是接近零气泡的
我们可以看到在这个GPU上
我们啊草稿在提出草稿
草稿模型在提出草稿
然后这个target模型在呃在前项
然后在PREFILE
然后在呃呃verify在确认
在确认的时候
我们这个CPU上的这个调度去这个schedule
就已经开始准备这个angel step
就是下一步下甚至下下步
那么就能保证我们在GPU上这一行
就是基本上是没有空闲的
能够做到最大限度地用上所有能用的算力
那么呃那么这个我们刚刚才讲过
这个隐藏状态就非常重要
然后我们也讲了啊
我们这个隐藏状态
这个HINSIX的提取是完全是VR arm原声的
那么呃我们到呃
我们这个呃刚才简单讲了
离线和在线两种两种不一样的方式
就是这个是一个比较呃
这个工程上engineering的这个问题了啊
我们有两种方法
一种是我们离线有什么问题吗
呃有有有同学有问题啊
就是说这个加速有多少是来自于呃自回归解码
有多少是来自于自适应的这个REVERIFIANCE
你能重复一下最后那个部分吗
呃就是这个加速有多少是来自于半自回归解码
有多少是来自于自适应
Verify length
哦嗯嗯这是好问题
又是一个好问题
呃在
VRM上面
我们已经支持了这个这个dynamic的呃
这个投机解码就是动态投机解码
但是现在的情况是你在部署的时候
你要这个用户
你呃你要说比如说在这个呃request呃
request请求的数量
比如说在1~5之间
我我我打八个草稿
然后在五到什么30或者之类的
我打我打呃
我我打五个草稿
然后如果他超过
比如说30个请求或者50个请求
那我就我就我就我就不我就不开这个呃
呃这个投机解码我就把它关掉嗯
但是这个是需要用户自己嗯
自己输就是自己输入的
那么现在VIVON它它对于迪斯spark来说
我们是现在先支持了这个Mark of chain嗯
但是但是那个confidence had那个嗯叫什么
中文叫呃知信度头
目前还没有在V2上面完全支持
所以我们这些数据都呃都是呃这个论文里面
这个致敬度投的数据是论文里面来的
我们接下来还还是要呃就是做更多的这个呃
呃OBASI嗯
research啊
才能才能看到底
就是这就是Mark of chain的加速和啊
但是好好的
有一点就是这这两个是分开的
两个不一样的这个mechanism
就是他们互相之间是就是不影响的
可以可以加起来
也可以就是一个就是只apply一个
然后在speculator上面我们是支持
就是就是两个都都都有训练的知识
只是愿望上面暂时还没有这个confidence had的
那个influence的支持
但是呃已经在我们已经在
我们已经在在work on it呃
这是正在进行中的工作
如果大家啊感兴趣的话
之后可以把一些pr branch分享给大家
可以大家可以呃就是尝鲜版抢先就是使用一下
如果感兴趣的话
好非常感谢嗯
那我继续吧
嗯就是我们提取这个hin st隐藏状态嗯
一个是我们呃先写入磁盘
就是啊再训练
我们就用VR这个target模型
就是啊跑很多PREFILE
然后得到这些HCS
但是有一个问题就是这些HSIX很大
尤其是对于这个大模型就很大的模型来说
像这样5.2的话
它重新生成
它需要就是占200多个tb的这个内存
那么你在这个生产环境中很少有
就是这个嗯这个luxury就是有有这个条件嗯
那么我们更好的就是训练方式
我们比较推荐的就是你在线训练嗯
一个是你这个离线写入磁盘的这些HSIZE
隐藏状态
你也没有办法再次使用了
因为他就是针对这一个模型的
你也不可能再用这个去训练其他的模型
那么等于说你就为了一次
然后你就占了这么200多个tb的这个内存
就很不划算
所以我们一般来说是推荐你就是在线的训练
一边一边产生这个在编二部署
然后产生这个呃hand states对隐藏状态
然后然后我们这个trainer会给VR这个end end point啊
发送一个批量的请求
然后然后然后回复到这个呃his states呃
呃给它提取过来
那么路径上面就是没有没有存储
我们用掉之后就删除
那么那么也不会占内内存
然后就是也比较方便
嗯那么在量我们目前是怎么样啊
把这个hen sex隐藏状态提取出来的
我们就是没有新的问为
他就是重新写一套这个ping这个提取的通路
我们我们就是使用了VR
他就是本身已经有的这个kv connector
然后我们在这个target前项的时候
我们抽出呃
His states
这个比如说第八层
23层
39层
50层
70层的这些hn states
然后我们把它伪装成一个KV
直接的装进这个KV的那个cash槽位里面
也不需要啊
reshape或者怎样
然后用这个kv connector把他送到训练器那边去
那么我们这个我我们这个TENSIZE
它的它的dimension是这个token token line
然后layer
然后这个HSI
然后我们就把这个labor核心的size啊
就是命令成这个non heads和head size
然后他就可以
我们发现可以直接这个严丝合缝的
就是嗯嗯就是嵌进这个KB的开始的槽位里面
就不用另外为他就是写一个通路
那么为什么我们现在就是想要用这个moon cake connector
有一点就是呃我们这个哎呀呃
这个机器隐藏状态的这个kv connector
他是呃
他要求我们这个trainer这部分和这个hn states
extract or这个connector这部分他是在同一个node上
在同一个机器上的
因为我们需要就是他能够呃两个互能
能能够之间互相沟通
然后他们呃共享呃一部分内存
这样子的话china才可以读到这个target写的东西
然后因为我们有很多这个a think呃
这种concurrency
在我们还有什么
给这个每一个hit says的文件放加一个file
然后这样子trainer读的时候哎我看看有没有lock
然后没有lock的时候
我在读取
就是嗯还要解决这个读写的冲突
那么实际上我们希望他这个connector他是可以进行
就是我们跨节点的训练的
因为现在很多模型都越来越大了
甚至可能一个node你都部署不下
那么更不要说我们我们就是在一个note上面
我们既要部署VR这个target模型
我们又要训练这个小的draft模型
那么那就是一个note现在根本就不够用了
所以我们我们就是希望就是在SPECULAR上面
能够支持这个跨节点的训练
而且就我们不假设他有这个呃
共享的那个文件的系统
然后我们希望就这个hit states隐藏状态的生产
和我们trainer训练这边的消费
就是是相对比较比较分开的
这个生产者就是他不需要知道我们谁来消费
什么时候消费
他只管把这个HSTATES嗯
这个隐藏状态给产生出来
然后他就放在它就放在一个地方啊
他不要来呃
就是关心这个调度的问题
那么我们trainer这边因为相对压力比较小
我们可以在这个训练的这个这个消费者这边啊
呃来呃
但关心这个调度的问题啊
来就是决定我们怎么读取
然后我们也希望他这个生成是有界的
就是可驱逐的
就如果出现某种
比如说一个trainer
他GPU它啊呃他掉线了
或者他就是害了
那么呃我们这个生产的速度
就是大于消费的速度了
我们就不要再一直继续的生产了
要不然的话我们之前训练的时候也遇到过
就是磁盘就是写写不下了
因为这边啊这边这边训练的已经没有
在没有在工作了
然后生产的还一直在生产
那这个就这个这个情况就很危险
那么我们希望它是有界的
那还有一些就是呃
比如说这个这个文件它已经存在10分钟
30分钟
很明显就是没有被及时的清理掉
那嗯嗯我我我们也希望可以直接把它驱逐掉
那么就是能保证我们这个storage这个内存的
这个啊健康
那那那那么那我们就发现
之前我们流量就是原声这个这个这个系统啊
它好像你稍微有一点不太够用了
所以我们现在就是准备啊使用这个monkeke connector
就是它既不需要我们有一个共享的文件系统
然后他又有这些有界啊
可驱逐
然后单边读取的这个能力
而且也不需要我们很多这个engineering power
来重新把这些功能写一遍
呃我们我们最近有一个P2
就是在这个speculate上面加一个这个moon cake connector
所以我们现在在SPECTOR上面就是可以做到
支持啊
我们跨节点的训练
那么就可以为像这种很大的
像kitty three啊这样的模型来训练一个draft的模型
就是进一步能够拓宽我们支持的这个
模型的这个家族
然后模型的这个选择嗯
我今天其实就是对
我想我也想打个广告啊
就是我们的第十期节目
当时是有专门讲的介绍
就是KV的connector
然后请到的就是艾m cash的一华
还有moon cake的嘉豪老师来介绍的
就直播间的呢对
然后直播间的同学如果感兴趣的话
也可以看一下那一期的回放
那我回然后看看对那期讲的挺好的
然后我们直播间有同学问训练的时候
生产者和消费者开相同的切分head的并行方式
可以直接p to p传对吗
呃
哦对应该是应该是可以的
对对
我觉得这个可能也是看mok connector
具体是怎么实现的对吧
嗯嗯嗯对
因为因为我虽然我没有做过这一块的训练
但是因为我做过一些那种呃
强化血这一块的后训练
它这一块儿的呃
就是传输方式
至少反正在权重传输这一块
它是有很多种传输后端的对吧
是对对对对对
然后他他是有p to p的传法
然后也有一些其他传法
比如ORGA
然后BCASTA
然后还有一些那种混合的传输方式
然后因为在我觉得很多时候训练里面
你的那个
我想想当然了
因为因为我们这个项羽是把hen space
把它拆成了类似于KV开启的格式去传的对吧
对对对
那么其实理论上来讲的话
我们应该是对于
比如说我们的这个头怎么切的话
不是那么敏感
因为因为不管你怎么切的话
我们最后反正都是传的
实际上是黑人死states是吧
最后我还是要把还原回去的
对对对对
实际上他怎么接不是特别重要啊
对对对
因为他对的这个ship没有那么对
你说的对
没有那么敏感对
然后呃这位同学又说我理解复用hidden states
应该跟pd分离没啥区别哦
哦有哦
就是说你和低扣的时候对
因为你也是穿黑灯
你也是开开是对对对对对对对对
是的对对啊
那最后就是不过
不过我我想的话就是因为我们在训练的时候话
可能就是因为一般来讲都会有DP这种维度嘛
对吧
那么实际上我们传到我们的
比如说训练的那个group里面之后
我是肯定得去要么做那个broadcast
要么的话我就是每个里面去
专门去单独去传一份对吧
就每个单独传的话
我觉得可能会让我们中间通信里面的
负载会比较高
对嗯这个这个pr我到时候也可以分享给大家
嗯然后大家可以试一试
或者有什么更好的这个呃实现的方式
也欢迎大家和我们讨论
嗯这个嗯等然后有同学问训练也支持pd分离吗
训练不太需要
实际上对
就一般来讲的话
就是你可能如果是你是有的时候也
有的时候会用
反
不过我确实没有用过
就是你的那个ROLT如果就是特别长的话
那你可能会需要做pd分离
然后我觉得在这个场景里面的话
我觉得他跟我们那个叉学习里面去做rot
其实有些很像的地方对吧
就是我们可能也需要让模型去采样
一个很长的一个序列
对呃实际上我们训练的时候
对于这个target大模型的话
我们基我们是不需要这个低扣的的
这个部分我们只是需要PFL这个部分哦
因为我只要这个he is st
我们对我们只要这个HST就弹地扣的抵扣
我们就让他抵扣子一个token
就是之后再说
我们根本不在一起
对因为我们学的是他那个logo pros这些东西对吗
对对
我们学的他是那个那个hit states作为输入
所以低扣的这个我们就是不需要啊
对我们其实主要就学了PSE
我们不需要去让他去完整的去输出所有东西
那么其实你的这个整个方法哈
其实还是类似于那种sf t对吧
嗯对我不太了解色气
对我我理解是应该是这样子的
嗯对好
然后还是有同学有问题
就是哪些VM的优化技术
不能和投机解码同时开启
哪些不可以和特级金版同时开启嗯
嗯我我目前为止没有遇到过
呃
好像说这两个不太兼容的
那vim有那个vim recipe
如果你在部署的时候可以去看一下
就是嗯我们有就是嗯enable这个投机解码
它有这个投机解码的recipe
然后你可以去看一下有没有
就是说和其他的不兼容的
然后然后怎么样就是部署又有后机结嘛
就是呃最呃最优化的方案啊
我们我们现在这个内部
也是在希望能够我们学习多学习一些
就是run time这个啊推理的时候的这个啊
VR这这个内容
然后这样我们也可以更好的给大家提供
这样的recipe
这然后就是争取给大家能够啊发布
就是最优化的表演的方案来部署我们的模型
对我理解的话
我们推荐码主要是在抵扣的时候去使用的对对
那么可能比如说一些你做prefer
相关的一些东西的话
可能就就可能会跟他就不会很兼容吧
嗯因为他就推的时候就没有这种推荐码
这种东西对
因为他他不加速PREFL
它只加速那个低扣
好我们继续吧
呃呃那就我今天就准备了这么多内容
然后希望大家能够体验一下我们的酷
然后如果大家觉得有帮助的话
能给我们一个信心
这对我们来说就是非常重要对
然后我在嘿嘿
大家可以就是我们这个web project下面所有项目
大家都可以习惯性的每给每个项目点个star哦
对对对对
这个星星对于我们来说就是我们的
我们的我们的怎么说呢
我们的本钱对
就是这是我们的指路明星对
而且投机解码这个东西真的是
我感觉现在应该所有的场景里面
都使用投机解码了
因为他真的是太好用了
对吧对的对的是的
因为他就是完全没有损失嘛
然后有损失的情况下
你把它关掉就好了
所以基本上是一个就是稳赚不赔的这样一个呃
优化方式
好呀
我在微信群里面把这些嗯
我这里有的那个呃链接什么都发发上去了
然后也有我的VR select的联系方式
还有我微信的联系方式啊
欢迎大家来啊
来那个就是来微信上面或者slab上面来找我
对诶
我还有个问题啊
就是比如说我们的野生开发者
比如他们自己去训练了一个什么模型呢对吧
那么能够贡献到你们的这个hn face仓库吗
可以呀
如果是用那个speculators来训练的话
当然更好了
那不就是相当于给我们这个免费的GPU吗
哈哈哈哈好
然后直播间的同学还有没有什么问题要问的呀
对吧嗯
今天直播
然后对
然后有同学问数据集一般准备多少合适哦
这是好问题
我们一般是准备500K就是五五十十万
50万是调数据是吧对呃
然后但是我们最近也在试验用那个perfect one
那个是那个是100万嗯
然后嗯之前我们是只是支持每一每一个对话
我们就是就是就是一轮的这样的这样的数据
但现在我们支持就是很多轮的这样的数据了
嗯我还有个问题
就是我们做这个头一解码模型训练的时候
可以从比如现在现成的一些模型上面
继续去做一个对于投一解码模型的一个
后训练吗
可以嗯
那我们是不是这样的话
需要数据就可以少一些呢
对是这样子的嗯
我们也有听说呃
有用户嗯用好像7万3万来微调翻庆
在他们自己的那个嗯
在他们自己的那个呃
production environment那些数据上面呃
然后然后能够得到一个比较好的加速
然后然后就是针对他们自己的这个优化嗯
然后secret上面也是支持的
就是你可以你可以啊
你可以就是用那个from pre trained这个flag
然后然后来嗯漏的一个啊已经训练好了
比如说deflash debug的模型
然后你再在你自己的数据上面进行微调
和反清嗯
还有一点就是所有的deflash model
都可以非常容易的被转换成despark model
Into a probe u
就是你可以就是只要你有这个desplash model
你可以很容易把它变成一个despark model
然后这也是就是一种优化方式嗯
然后还有同学问一个问题
就是度模态模型呃
怎么训练呢
我们有支持这个图像数据
然后我知道有用户在使用我们的这个库来进行
这个我猫是猫time model吧
这样的模型的这个训练嗯
但是我们自己还没有时间做这个相关的研究
如果大家感兴趣的话
可以就是告诉我们
这个有什么哪些需要改进的地方啊
然后或者有哪些好的数据库我们需要支持的对
然后呃我理解冻魔胎数据的话
我们是不是就像于是就图像那一块地方
就肯定是不可能去用来做这个模型的预测了
对吧
对对对
因为我们只能加速
就是嗯就是文字的那个部分嗯
然后有同学问RL一般会考虑投机解码
对RL一般那种都会开的嗯
然后max token如果训练的时候设置小了
比如2048要重新训练吗
哦这是个好问题嗯
就是之前我们发现你训练的时候
这个max model s开到多少
那然后你你这个uh inference inference的时候呃
他过了这个max model length
这个performance就会有比较很明显的这个退化
那我们现在是就是我们现在
我们现在就是给他加了一个这个sliding
window attention的这个优化嗯
嗯就是我们发现加了这个优化之后
你训练的这个嗯模型就max model life可以稍微短一点
然后你inference的时候
你在用的是什么几万什么context的话
他这个呃呃regression
就这个就不会非常就不是非常明显了
甚至就是可以持平嗯
然后呃我们也在做这些啊
就是特别特别长的这些long context的这些啊
训练的时候的优化
如果你想用什么什么呃
很长很长的什么一个MANLION的话
我们希望未来你训练的时候也可以就是支持他
嗯嗯嗯然后有同学问个问题
diffusion哦
DLM可以用投机解码吗
你没必要吧
就是就是我觉得嗯
首先我感觉好像大家是正儿八经落地的话
其实用DR模式很少的对吧对
因为不是JA出的那个
diffusion的那个那个模型嘛
然后然后感觉好像表现不是特别理想
因为我们刚才说了那个病情的问题
他这个并行的话
就是会会有这个呃精确度不够的这个问题
这个是就是很难解决对
其实我在第二幕刚出时
我还当时研究了一下他这个模型的
其实在我看来
这个马尔可夫投这个改进的话
某某城商类似于一种回归传统钓二目的方式
因为以前第二幕他其实不是我一口气去
就是比如说解码16个token的
他可能是比如说呃1024个token里面
他每次解码两到三个这种样子
然后他每次都是输出这个概率最大的两个
所以当时其实他是有一个先后顺序的
对
只是把它转成了这种推荐码方式里面
大家就不做这种先后顺序了
然后我每次解码数量比较少
我就解码8~16个
然后这时候就出现了这种
这个一口气全部升了所有token
然后就导致这个这个模型的能力变得弱了很多
其实这个东西就是最开始做这个方向的时候
当时大家都发现了这个问题的
对对对对哦
实际上你要硬要加的话
应该也是可以加的
我觉得嗯嗯但是就是感觉没有必要对
当然我但我反正想想象不了这个东西
加州他是个怎么样的推理方法
不知道有没有
不知道有没有意义对
而且现在也没有做DMM的专门的推理引擎
好像就你你你应该只能用那个传送门来做嗯
哦VIO是支持像这个加general diffusion的
嗯实际上那个VR里面的JA的fusion的支持很多
就是用这个d flash来做的
就是来来使用
我们有一期那个van的呃
office hour是我们有个同事
他他来讲这个究竟是怎么实现的
如果大家有感兴趣的话
我也可以发到群里面
对这个可以发群里
我们研究一下
学一学嗯
好好那么非常感谢嘉文老师今天的分享啊
没有没有没有没有嗯
跟大家共一起学习
然后今天的直播我们就到此结束了啊
感谢